hello everyone my name is Marisol and
I've been making videos at the piano
covering topics related to practicing
performance and composition today I'd
like to show you my setup and share with
you some tips I have on filming the
keyboard with an overhead ankle the
camera that I use is a nikon d750 with a
20 millimeter F 2.8 manual lens for
capturing audio I usually use a rode
videomicro which is recording the sound
right now or I use a zoom h5 if I'm
using a digital keyboard so far I've
been using the sounds from Logic Pro X
but I plan to upgrade this very soon so
finding the right camera for this setup
is actually the easiest part you can
choose to go with a DSLR a mirrorless
both with full or cough sensors or any
other camera that supports a high enough
resolution and that supports the use of
a wide-angle lens so if your camera has
a full-frame sensor I recommend
something wider than 24 millimeters if
you have a crop sensor somewhere in the
range between 10 to 18 millimeters is
perfect the most important part of the
setup is to figure out how to mount the
tripod the tripod that I use is made by
K&F concept and it allows me to extend
the arm at a 90 degree angle so
basically it extends upwards and bends
to the side so this part of the tripod
is extremely important because it allows
me to extend the camera so that it's
hanging directly over the keyboard to
handle the weight of the DSLR camera I
use a counterweight what I do is I take
a neoprene lens cover any sort of pouch
will do and a five to eight pound
dumbbell so I just put it in and make
sure it's secure and using this cloth
handle I'll hang it on to the tripod so
here's some footage of me setting up
from scratch because I'm constantly
moving my setup from piano to piano it's
very important for me to keep things
very portable and practical to keep
things efficient I have markings on each
of the tripod legs which indicate how
long I should extend them
I put two legs on the music stand and
one leg onto the closed lid towards the
back so even though the setup is more
practical than say a ceiling mount or
some sort of massive heavy duty crane
tripod that extends overhead it's still
fancier than normal so that being said
I'd like to explore ways to recreate the
setup using different cameras and
different tripods
first off let's try this with my phone
which is an lg g5 now this has a
wide-angle camera which is why I chose
to use this phone in the first place I
understand that most phones don't have
this capability but with most phones you
can also buy an attachment which turns
the camera lens into something more wide
to mount the phone onto the tripod I'm
using this gadget by lanzi there are
many products similar to this but this
is just the one I had on hand I first
set this up onto the normal tripod that
I use and here's some footage directly
from the phone next I mounted it onto a
more ordinary tripod one that doesn't
have a 90-degree extension here's some
footage with that setup so I actually
just have the tripod on the short sticks
on this keyboard right here so you can
probably recreate this on a grand piano
as well the only thing with this setup
is that the audio from the phone is not
so great but that can be easily fixed by
using a separate audio device to capture
the sound and syncing it in post next up
is a Logitech webcam so the focal length
of this webcam is definitely wider than
most others I still had to push my
tripod up very high in order to capture
the whole keyboard this is okay though
because the webcam is extremely light
a lot of things can be slightly improved
with video editing here's an example of
that with the webcam footage so this is
so it's not bad it's possible by the way
I forgot to mention if you're using a
tripod like this which I described
that's being very ordinary it will have
a ball head like this so it you can
rotate it any way you want but most
tripods actually don't have this if it
doesn't then consider getting this you
can probably get it for a few bucks on
Amazon or Ebay and it essentially screws
on to the top of the tripod and allows
you to have that full ball movement and
there are various degrees of how fancy
you can get with these ball mounts but
this super important so that's it for
the setup and this video please let me
know in the comments if you found this
useful or if you've tried something
similar to this before or if you already
have a better solution but anyway thank
you so much for watching please
subscribe if you haven't already and
I'll see you in the next video